today on the anime zone a review of the
anime movie summer wars an anime that
explores the endless possibilities when
it comes to our use of technology i mean
think about it in just a few years time
can you imagine what we can do with the
kind of systems that will be in place
welcome to the world of oz the online
platform that allows you to control your
life and everything around it in this
digital world limitless possibilities
are just a few clicks away at the touch
of your fingertips how may i serve you
today
i couldn't
the advent of social media has become a
huge part of everyone's lives in recent
years and is only growing in influence
you have facebook the place that proves
that everyone has around 900 friends
that they actually know about one
percent of twitter the place where you
can see when someone has successfully
picked their nose and would like to tell
the whole world about it youtube proving
that television can successfully become
obsolete using a combination of cats
fail videos and pewdiepie tumblr a place
for homoerotic fanfictions and doctor
who gifts and finally reddit and 4chan
which i'm convinced are actually used by
some of the world's most skilled and
talented geniuses in the world who'd
much rather spend their spare time
making memes so what happens if you put
all social media into one place summer
wars
kinda well
it's only really one part of the movie
that's just like shut up this opening
paragraph is totally related to the
movie okay in the near utopian feature
where the online world has become this
peaceful friendly place our lives have
been integrated with the world of oz an
online platform that is essentially an
extension of yourself in the virtual
world entire real world systems are
reliant on odds and pretty much everyone
use it so basically it's an ultra
advanced happy-go-lucky version of the
internet without trolls cat videos or
porn probably back in the real world
kenji koi so is just your average
teenager who's found himself in an odd
predicament being the runner-up in the
math olympics he didn't have much
planned this summer but somehow he's
found his way traveling all the way to
the countryside on an odd job set up by
his high school crush natsuki what he
doesn't know is that the job entails a
bit more than he first thought
absolutely not just pretend you're my
boyfriend okay i can't do it genji will
make a wonderful addition to the family
while kenji tries his best to fit in
with natsuki's large extended family
things get even worse when he receives a
mysterious encoded text message which he
manages to solve not knowing that he's
accidentally just released a dangerous
virus onto us known only as love machine
shut up it's a threatening name alright
with love machine wreaking havoc within
the world of oz the repercussions are
slowly being felt within the real world
and as things get more and more chaotic
and the stakes are raised even higher
kenji and family slowly realized that
this little computer virus could pose a
bigger threat to the world than anyone
had previously
your fault imagined
what's happening
i mean
this isn't real right
it's just a game
isn't it
now anime original movies aren't
something i normally do but at the same
time are often overlooked unless
miyazaki is making his next blatant
message about war and nature or when his
name happens to rhyme with shmushmira
but considering this is directed by my
favorite up-and-coming director mumrahu
soda who did films such as the girl who
left through time and more recently army
and yuki wolf children i wanted to shine
some light on him to get the technical
aspects out of the way first well the
movie looks great visually speaking the
animation is fluid and smooth with
barely any moments where anything is
just still they managed to make a stark
contrast between the standard real world
setting and the world of oz which is a
bright and vibrant place that looks like
what would happen if the internet had
sex with nintendo except i have no idea
what the [ __ ] this thing is here in the
middle considering it looks like a
[ __ ] cat going through an acid trip
on top of this the soundtrack consists
of orchestral music that feels very
disney-esque in the upbeat and comical
moments but still manages to hit home
during the very emotional points and
sounds
great the acting in both sub and dub is
also great so uh how can i put this into
a nutshell it's all [ __ ] great there
now with the boring stuff out of the way
let's get into the real meat of this
review the characters and plots
characters were actually the weakest
part since with such an enormous cast
even the main characters which were
basically kenji and natsuki get very
little development kenji being the usual
shy and quirky teenager living his
average high school life of trying to
get senpai to notice him whose only
standout trait being that he's really
really really good at maths
asians eh and natsuki being the love
interest who
you know what has very little relevance
to the story until the final climax then
you have the rest of natsuki's huge
extended family which probably have
enough members to start a small nation
individually they don't get too much
screen time but special mention goes to
the 90 year old grandma of the family
aka ball's grandma who is the outright
star of this movie as head of the family
she looks over everyone with a kind
heart but also gains respect from all of
them i mean just look at this clip here
and tell me that it doesn't feel like a
gangster interrogation
this great granddaughter of mine is no
pushover are you man enough to make my
nutsky happy is she about to shoot him
oh uh
maybe [ __ ] wrong sir i'm asking you if
you're man enough
yeah oh man this isn't looking good for
him yeah i guess man enough to die for
her oh [ __ ] he's dead yes
just run now run while you can on a
serious note though she brings so much
heart into this film and honestly while
the characters may be the weakest part
of the movie that didn't bother me much
and i'll explain why a bit later now
it's hard to talk about the plot of the
movie without spoiling too much but to
address the huge elephant in the room
yes the plot of the movie is essentially
a rehash of the digimon movie our war
game right down to the art style of the
digital world not that it actually
bothered me much since both were made by
the same director anyway and as much as
i liked digimon as a kid it's just
[ __ ] digimon guys and this story was
too great to be content within that
franchise that's all i'll say on that
matter because if you have seen the
digimon movie don't worry because summer
wars is done like a 10 gillion times
better yes there is a number i just made
up on the spot and if you haven't seen
it then even [ __ ] better the digital
aspect of the film is an interesting
look at the possible consequences as our
lives get more and more integrated with
technology but it manages to do it
without being too deep and complicated
since this is a family film after all so
they managed to keep things simple
enough for even the kiddies to
understand though the technology in this
film is sometimes simplified to a point
that it makes very little sense for
example i don't know why this kid is so
good at fighting games just cause he
learns martial arts in real life because
last time i checked practicing karate
does [ __ ] all when you're trying to
remember a 72 button combination to do a
gay you can and for the record why is
the computer virus called love machine i
mean that name could mean anything from
a really heavy womanizer to the world's
most emotional vibrator but it certainly
doesn't sound like a scary computer
virus that could possibly [ __ ] the
world technological simplifications
aside though the plot is fun and manages
to keep you interested and entertained
throughout so fun in fact that you'll be
cheering a climax based on a card game
that apparently no one actually knows
how to play
will you declare coicoy
yeah that's right
that [ __ ]
i have absolutely no idea what's going
on now i have a confession to make this
is my favorite anime film of all time
and something that i have a ridiculous
amount of personal attachment to but to
properly explain why i've got to go
serious for a second and explain
something about my own morals as a
person rather than being that cheeky
sarcastic [ __ ] on the internet so if the
thought of me being sincere for once
sickens you then i suggest you click off
this video now or just grab a bucket the
technological aspects of the plot really
only take up half the film and the real
reason why this is my favorite anime
film of all time is because of the
family which is what gives summer wars
its heart and soul the underlying morals
the film portrays is the concept of
family and how important it is family
should be the people that always have
your back are always there whether you
like it or not and it's not just the
family you're related to by blood it's
the family you adopt for yourself the
family you've been introduced into and
the friends you choose to introduce it's
an invisible bond that stays with you no
matter how many members are in it and
something you should never turn your
back on
some members you may get along well with
some you may not and others you may not
know that well but no matter what you
all share the bond of being in the same
family and it is one thing that no one
should go without this film portrays
that so well and with such a large cast
you could argue that the characters were
the weakest and least developed part but
that wasn't the point of it the family
itself felt like one massive character
that was reminiscent of all those family
reunions you'd used to have the
thanksgiving meals and the christmas
dinners you'd have your grandparents the
drunk uncles the nosy aunts the cousins
you do or don't look forward to hanging
out with and the hyperactive kids every
single member played a part into giving
this family its own character its own
heart its own soul and that's what
really makes the emotional moments hit
home as a family you share each other's
sufferings and each other's happiness
and you could feel the togetherness that
everyone held towards each other which
is a concept i hold very close to myself
personally
and that is why this came out to be my
favorite anime film of all time overall
summer wars is a bundle of fun that
should not be missed by anyone i'm not
gonna [ __ ] and say that i'm not
slightly biased because of the values
and morals that match up so closely to
my own which makes this my favorite
anime film but even without that it's a
highly entertaining look at how
technology can affect us all along with
a heartfelt story that is friendly for
the entire family it's slightly cheesy
and predictable at times but who cares
you should be watching this anyway and
you'll damn well walk out with a huge
smile across your face currently summer
wars is licensed by funimation and
unfortunately is not available for legal
streaming but is available for dvd and
blu-ray so get off your lazy asses and
go get it and while you're there tell
them giggux sent you
hey guys giggup here i hope you enjoyed
that review and i hope you're enjoying
youtube geek week at least i hope it's
youtube geek week right now otherwise
this is gonna sound very stupid and
random but whatever before we go i've
got one quick announcement to make i am
going to be attending alcon in leicester
from the 5th of september to the 8th of
september so if you've ever wanted to
see me in person and i don't know maybe
hang out or some gay [ __ ] like that then
come hang out at alcon with me i'll make
a proper announcement video later but
yeah that's it for now if you're new to
my videos then you can check some of my
other reviews and [ __ ] here and if you'd
like me to see why don't just give me a
subscribe and stuff i don't know and
don't forget you can follow me on both
facebook and twitter in the description
below anyway that's it for now i've been
giggling i hope you've enjoyed my review
and i'll see you all next time